let's chat now should we do Jenny
Chapman uh joining us as the chat
office hello
morning
did the labor party know about the
reputation of uh Mr pincher before these
allegations surfaced
I think there were widespread rumors I
find it impossible to believe that the
Prime Minister wasn't aware of them
particularly as we've now had reports
about Boris Johnson himself saying that
Chris pincher was
hansi that he was picture by name
pincher by Nature with the idea that he
shouldn't have had concerns because he
didn't know anything I think is just
beyond most people's uh belief
how much did labor know
well we we knew we heard rumors just
like everybody else we were surprised
that
um this person was put in a position
where he'd be responsible for
um welfare and discipline in Parliament
um on behalf of the conservative party
you know the labor party isn't consulted
on who the the government puts in its
whips office but I can tell you that had
this happened and uh kirst Armor's
leadership in the labor party it would
not have been handled like this at all
you know care would not be thinking
what's best for me what's best for my
friends he would put the national
interest parliament's interests before
his own what rumors had you heard
I'd heard remotes because there had been
allegations made and complaints had been
made previously I believe so you know
that and that's all in the public domain
so it's not as if the labor party was
getting some kind of Insider information
that nobody else had and keeping it to
itself these things were were known and
were documented and you know it was
widely circulating so you know despite
all of that what kind of person decides
you know what we need to do with this
guy we need to give him a really big
promotion because that's what Boris
Johnson did and he did it because it's
his mate and we think that's wrong why
didn't you bring it to the attention of
the commons authorities if you'd heard
these rumors
the comments everybody knew okay
honestly this is why didn't you bring it
to the attention of the authorities why
don't you make a formal complaint there
were there were complaints that had
already been made that's the point and
Boris Johnson knew that those complaints
had already been made he chose to ignore
that fact because it's his friend
contrast that with the way Neil Parish
was treated quite rightly he resigned
his position as a member of parliament
when he became um it became clear he'd
been watching pornography in the House
of Commons that's absolutely right that
he took that step but because Neil
Parish was not one of Boris Johnson's
friends he was dealt with in a
completely different way that's wrong
that's not how you should run a
government this the you know these are
this is a group of people who are
running our country making decisions
that affect our mortgages our pensions
our children's lives and we think that
that's the wrong way of doing it
so just to clarify you accusing the
prime minister of sleaze cronyism and
double standards
I could not put it back in myself but
what we've done today
um formally the chair of the labor party
anna-lysa Dodds has written to the Prime
Minister asking the questions that every
journalist has been asking over the
weekend about when did he know what did
he know
and why was that decision taken to put
Mr pincher in that position that
Letter's gone and we shall see what
happens next
um let's move on should we talk about
strike second week of Barrister strikes
beginning today and we saw quite a few
labor MPS including Shadow ministers on
the picket lines with the rmt I'm not
aware that any action has been taken
against them by KIA stammer even though
he said that they shouldn't do it are
you
I don't know I'm not
um probably most people are glad that
I'm not responsible for uh discipline in
the Parliamentary labor party
um but those decisions will be taken by
the chief Whip and I'm not privy to
those discussions at all yes It's Tricky
isn't it because you know um you're busy
so you don't always know what's going on
prime minister is running the country
doesn't always know what's going on
but why did he say picture by name
pincher by Nature well we don't know
that he did we don't know that he said
that we know that Dominique Cummings
said that he said that and some of the
things that Dominic Cummings has said
has proven to be not um economical with
the actuality it's it's not just Dominic
Cummings though is it um and we have
government ministers uh I think
corroborating those sorts of comments so
I I think it's very you know they can
look as well at the comment that the at
the number 10 put out that Boris Johnson
was not aware of any specific
allegations now I think the use of the
word specific is do you know that word
is doing a lot of heavy lifting in that
sentence and you know we find it very
very hard to believe that the Prime
Minister didn't know about these
allegations decided to put his friend in
that top job anyway and we think that's
wrong and yeah don't please okay let me
move on sorry uh don't please forgive
their findings on the investigation into
secure armor by the as early as today is
what my newspapers are telling me this
morning you could be looking for a new
leader by the end of the week
I think so I think but obviously we do
need to wait and see what Durham Police
conclude I have a huge amount of respect
for Durham Police I live in Durham
Police area
um but you know Kia has said what he
said about the outcome of that
investigation and we haven't had it yet
so let's wait and see what the police
have concluded
I read with interest this morning that
um although the leader even if he is
defined could offer his resignation the
NEC the ruling body of the labor party
doesn't have to accept that resignation
do you think that if he does offer his
resignation over this they should accept
it
I think kids been very clear about how
he views this you know he stood up and
said that if he was fined that he would
resign that that is what he said so I I
I think it's you know I think lots of
people are trying to figure out
different ways that he could maybe get
away from that or distance from that
comment that he made but you know I I
think that he's bit because he is
somebody with a huge amount of Integrity
you know he was very clear about what he
would do what the NEC would choose to do
clearly is a matter for the NEC
um but I think care could not have been
clearer in his statements on this
so you think they should accept his
resignation if it comes to it
I I think it's difficult to imagine a
situation
um as you've just described but let's
see what happens when Durham
um you know tell us the outcome of their
investigation I'm confident that here
isn't going to get fined you know I I
don't somebody I know reasonably well
and I just cannot see the situation
where he is going to get fined in the
way that that people think I mean I was
reading on Twitter over the weekend that
he's been fined and kept it a secret and
it's just nonsense
um but um you know let's let Durham
police do their job ah Twitter that font
of all knowledge it's good to talk to
you thanks very much indeed for joining
us much appreciated